you are coming to the stream I hope you
are all fine greetings to all of you in
the chat and yeah the best news first
this is me being online streaming on a
new internet connection hooray
yeah I hope it works I mean it does work
but I hope it is reliable and you you
never know yeah it actually just turned
out to be a painless process my provider
cut me off switched everything off late
yesterday and this is me being on with
the German Telecom Deutsche Telekom yeah
usually they are they are yeah well
there they are also not great but you
can hope that it that it is better than
what I had perform okay so what am I
going to do that's a good question I
have no clue I have no plans and what to
do I could play a tone hood what
tournaments on Italian game no not not
this one we have an hourly Blitzen how
many bullets and how it is super blitz I
had unity media before cable internet
yeah maybe maybe let's go for us super
blitz arena yeah why not this is kind of
relaxing yeah I thought I had unity
media before cable and it was Jerry
speaking not too bad at the very
beginning at the cool that's a cool
pairing should hood in the chair of
course so unity media was kinda became
at my old place where I lived in this
book
any problems there but when I moved to
to my current location it got really
really awful it was unstable and yeah -
to the point of being unacceptable so
after two years I live here for exactly
two years yeah I was able to simply
terminate this contract and switch to a
new provider okay I'm not totally
certain about the c6 move
maybe f6 is kind of okay for black this
I thought would be really nice
how does he cover his legs you know like
that but not a happy move I think do I
just take it probably should be button
from white huh if I take pawn takes
there's still pretty substantial
pressure hello - Lord Kinbote and squall
square Dec then D turtle and folks
yonder Jett we get a couple of more
observers here in the Twitter stream 41
currently the set look okay well I
wonder it's my browser source working
now have no and here I did not have any
message yet of new subscribers or
followers and usually there's something
happening and I hear nothing I hope this
is not a defunct
and no I could watch Magnus I was having
a lesson
I know he was on for for most of the
evening
so I'm gaining a bit more space 1987 I'm
always playing so badly against security
I don't know what I'm doing there it is
just so so terrible what I'm doing
against him I play like a complete idiot
in those games and always from really
nice position this is just
now I can resign this game I cannot this
is just a full rook basically I always
play like a complete idiot against him I
really don't know what it is I don't
even know if I ever won a game it's
really really bad okay so that was a
fantastic start of this event so and
this I don't hear anything yeah it's
weird I have to check this I hope maybe
I have to somehow change the setup there
I mean I don't know why I should change
something because I worked before of it
okay the dolphin dreamer know fairly
equalized position my Bishop one b6
looks a little bit weird should
definitely try to improve this piece
so I beat shik who at least one step I
don't know it's very weird no I don't I
don't take any new students at the
moment I'm sorry
then the turtle
it is just with with in essence and at
some point you simply have to have to
close shop because if it's too much you
simply if there are too many you simply
are not able to provide any any decent
decent service let's say and I basically
decided last year to to stop taking new
students so that the ones that I have
can actually expect a proper proper job
it's that good the queen is hanging and
I'm threatening Queen age five so called
age five double check
and now it mate
so I was a reasonably good game at least
I should have probably deserved but I
didn't have the presence of mind to do
so if the question Matt gtk is 13 gr
says they can play game blind and can
solve technical exercise but over the
board it takes ages to calculate stuff
so what does that mean them you does
that mean you have some problems
generally over the board or just into
over the board games because one did
thing definitely is the case of your
train on the computer the whole time
using a screen and the two-dimensional
board you have sometimes issues - yeah
to visualize correctly on a
three-dimensional board I have the same
issue actually I'm always doing it at a
computer and if you yeah playing on a
real board you sometimes have issues
with visualization because I'm simply
not used to the two dimensions anymore
yeah so if this is your issue I can
relate and the only way to fight it is
to continue to to to go on to go with
with real board once in a while yeah
there was a question from there was a
question if I can recommend a different
German coach no I mean there are
certainly people but I cannot like of
the bed recommend somewhat somebody
not of course I don't want to I mean
this is not a matter of competition or
so where I would definitely recommend
something but I'm not I'm not aware okay
what's what's going on here yeah he
won't get this but Queen g7 is also
quite an important thing here for for
from black yeah that's you I could try
to shoot for a higher blitz rating
that's something that I have in mind
g3 I should win the rupiah against
Masoli
yeah should be the rook Queen to e7
that's actually 95 that's it's better
than taking the rook not much but a
little bit how's the weather in
temperature and and your places there in
the chat it's damn cold in Germany I
mean here it's not super cold but I was
really I was drinking so much tea today
a really hot t minus 10 that's that's
minus 12 okay okay so I'm a full hookup
I don't have the DTS nemesis no not
normally
would be actually nights of my opponent
will simply resigned the game would save
me a little bit of time it's made almost
oh and would have primo troop g5 that is
still made okay Donny ray oh oh okay
there's a following message so that this
actually work okay I did preserve
yeah this is okay for me I can okay take
my for next unfortunately it's just
equal it's not like I'm better wait
Bishop cakes it's not have to move
I think I can take take their rent
I'm quite happy here with the berserk
and his disposition is somewhat somewhat
manageable the only thing is it's just
it's just entirely entirely boring
that's going to be difficult to win
basically no matter how good or bad the
opponent is yeah and he's heard about
this thing here that you should put the
pawns on the other color all of the
bishops color engage Magnus model Jim I
might lose it er ever play for wind to
harden okay I think I can stand us and
maybe he plays it doesn't do it him go
for King and pawn ending which would
have been nice for me maybe winning even
I hope I'm not overdoing it but ok Kingi
- I have to show it to Jim
just just very equal Jim maybe even
again some space there if I can put this
bishop on to f3 and maybe I can dominate
this yet so it still looks very dry but
if I can get to h3 maybe then ah ha ah
ha ha ha he's doing something
okay at least there's some sort of
imbalance now aha
so we put some points on light squares
maybe I should have played King d6 first
actually and I'm winning a pawn in the
game and it's needed to be a bit patient
okay yeah the end game mode and game
mode so 10th place yeah I'm getting
closer getting closer yeah I was of
course totally dead with name you have
to we have to play and hope for some
some mistake
berserk berserk
yeah
why do top GM's start to stream that's
an interesting question
to be honest and I completely understand
why I'm let's say the second-tier GM's
start to stream or why people like I
stream there is definitely a certain
financial incentive you can say suddenly
learn a bit of money not like much money
but there are some there are some
possibilities to earn earn money but in
case of like Magnus I mean he doesn't
need the money
for sure and he just wants to have some
fun and this is probably the main
incentive it's fun to do okay so here I
try to get something going on the
kingside Queen to f6 would be cool and
he finds a good move really good very
well played by black very well played by
my opponent
maybe I should have played this a bit
differently again
hindsight is twenty-twenty quinta a
seven Knights got this check okay so I
probably have to do this cannot take you
to the back rink yeah after this this
tournament I might do some newer
challenges haven't thought about it
ready what I will do
it's a it's a completely winning ending
Emily just go to the queenside
[Music]
the 22 seconds are a bit of an issue so
just push the air Poonam
okay yeah I see yeah see in the Czech
mm-hmm my review of inside mores black
rubber topic is causing a steel on
chesil okay funny I have to have to read
up on that I did not did not read that
yeah I made a video review on that book
and it is it is just a terrible book hey
I'm sorry I'm sorry yeah it's just
terrible and I have no other way to
describe it okay filleted tie pesto
what makes a chess book good or bad
that's a good question
yeah no joke just on my channel there's
a book review from I think December it
could have been Christmas Day actually
December 24th 25th or something um okay
what makes a terrible book or a good
book and many things in case of this
particular book that are absolutely
hated it is simply the selection of
lights
I mean the author recommends many lines
that are just downright terrible and I
don't understand why you would recommend
lines that are known as terrible for a
very long time
it's simply bad recommendations you look
at the lines and you say why why would
you play this crap yeah and that was the
problem
yeah
and and completely unnecessary because I
mean there are so many good lines that
you can recommend why would you need to
recommend something terrible
yeah for example he recommends the
Hubbins counter gambit for black and I
mean this is in itself is is terrible
and it's just a bad opening that doesn't
work but the the worst thing is that he
combines it if white avoids the alvin's
yeah with 90 or 3 on move - he wants to
play a stone wall in an absolutely
unplayable fashion I totally understand
that the target group is not chess
professionals yeah so the standards that
I probably have for opening repertoire
is different to what many of the
potential buyers need however there is
no need to recommend crap it's just not
necessary there are many good openings
around that you can recommend and write
a book about yes oh I don't get it why
do I recommend nonsense yeah that that's
it mostly I mean the elements count
again but if you if you do it
like I understood the I kind of
understand some point of the author and
it says that yeah the Hubbins needs to
need to active play and so on yes I
totally understand but it's still an
opening that's basically refuted and why
would you recommend something that is
crap you can give one active piece play
against on d4 where you can easily build
a repertoire base let's say on the
Queens gambit accepted that is a fully
playable opening and and completely
completely sound it's played by karana
or other strong grandmasters and you
could recommend that why recommend
something that doesn't work I know
I think it's just fishing form for bias
because the husband's yeah I know my
Rosa which played the Alvin's that's
what they all say but he played it 20
years ago and things have changed you
nowadays we actually analyze stuff and
prepare and so on so what's going on
here white is playing this very well
very well
yeah a three years oh my should be six
so it doesn't do it this is also enough
my god stop playing this well that
doesn't work I know I played just
absolutely perfectly this game this guy
Wow I really have a hard time when when
the books are terrible I mean I kind of
understand you can have different
different opinions about things but this
was just like too much I know you're
also wrote a book for for the white
pieces and maybe this is better I don't
know
but the black repertoire I really didn't
like the Budapest with 94 my habits also
bad you know there's a reason why nobody
plays these openings they're just
terrible
sorry yeah the bank how is a good active
opening but the idea of this book see my
first chest opening repertoire and I
really think if you start our you
probably don't want to start out of the
bank oh because it's a really
complicating and it's not really an
opening that promotes um let's say
classical values all that much and it's
something that at the very beginning
when we when you learn the repertoire
should be a focus do something then it's
a bit more classical and the the Banco
is a tough opening already it's a good
opening but a tough opening the Kings
gambit yeah what to say about the Kings
gambit this is the Kings gambit is a
very viable
I think surprise weapon not sure that
you want to play it too often but I mean
the Kings gambit is better than the
Alvin's okay I'm trying to snatch some
material here against all 88 and I think
it works
I have to be somewhat quick but I think
I manage I think one of the main things
with an opening book is it should
somehow fit the target group there is
really something something important if
you I mean there are those grand master
repertoire books for example you know or
other books by quality chess they are
fantastic
in terms of let's say scientific
accuracy but can you really use them
it's the problem I mean I could maybe
use this level analysis at some point
here for my opponents when I play I am
GM's
but to be honest I cannot drive memorize
that I cannot it just just can't and
this is if I cannot memorize it I know
that the typical Club player cannot
memorize it and there are many people
with the 1700 rating who buy those books
the GM repertoire books and those books
they won't help they simply won't help
because they would need something far
more far more let's say condensed into
the most important things and this is
actually the the reason why I'm making
this keep a simple repertoire
at the moment producing this for for
chest above a video released because I
felt you need to give people something
that they can actually memorize yeah
building a repertoire around the snake
bin only you ever thought about why
nobody plays a snake baloney there is a
reason and the reason is quality of the
line even though the snake Pannonia is
at least tricky moses was really working
fine so i feel i shall be better with
all those pawns and the wacky look on a7
the old Indian and the philidor's yeah
that's a good combination of lines the
fatigue there wasn't an underestimated
opening I think there are some ways what
he gives me the Queen there are some
ways to to make it tricky for white
while studying this for my own wide
repertoire with c4 I recognized that the
snake benoni is interesting it really is
interesting one one reason is that it is
definitely usually unknown for the white
player this is what Marais recommends
yeah and after Bishop f4 black is just
in bad shape and he actually gives that
line in his in his book and give
something that's terrible for black and
doesn't improve on it it's just really
funny
yeah Annie lass does a good job here
places quite well I'm definitely worth
him Queen to b3 looks good now I have
Ruby eight maybe just not a good
Stonewall a good opening for 1700 player
with black against e4
yeah you know I always recommend the
Queens gambit accepted or you can also
go for the Queens gambit declined but I
like the Queens gambit accepted a lot
thankfully cheer I don't even know how
much it's someone that isn't shown the
Queens gambit accepted is a completely
underrated opening it's never played on
the amateur level and it's pretty good
hey I should play cambered with right
sure yeah I can do that yeah yeah if you
subscribe to prime subscribe with
primary yeah you can do do that every
I'm happy to play King's gambit anyway
it's it's funny
not the Albin's please
[Laughter]
[Music]
things were subscribing my BA okay so I
tried to keep my knight on c5 there are
many opening suggestion
yeah then yeah the nihms o is a good
opening that's true but he asked for
1700 yeah if you if you study the NIM
zone you need a partner opening you just
don't need to live though you need a
Queen's Indian or BOGO Indian or benoni
or something else and then you need
something against the catalog and you
need something against this in there
yeah it's quite a bunch of lines and the
Queens gambit accepted on the other hand
has the charm of simply being on the
board on move too
and that makes it not not easier to
learn wow he really just wants to shut
everything down him I'm not going to
play ball here this is probably not
great but I just want to open it up okay
not sure if that was a good idea I'm
currently ahead on the clock okay that
was bad
I wanted to activate this Bishop wire b5
but he prevented that Neal ass is
playing well he just plays a little bit
slowly and will now probably lose our
time yeah just what it is he just plays
to slowed him we win on time even though
I deserved
for the qga no I mean I think there's a
book by Dell chef which is not bad I
mean actually have that book it is not
bad
and I've played the qga on some
occasions it's um this is a gap in the
market hint hint
yeah it it might be something that I
explore in the future oh I had that and
as a book pirates eat honor but that is
that's really old
okay yes Queen takes before I just
recognized that how to win this him me
is to take with the pawn f4 c6 maybe
c6 kind of holds I probably have to
write that book on the Queens gambit
accepted
threatening mate qga seems hard to play
why I think it's a super easy opening to
play what is complicated about the qgm
so an ending
I would I would have prefer to mate but
it didn't work out okay let's make this
hook on his heaven stable and let the
pawns decide the issue yeah you have to
know some stuff against really for in
the qga sure but the good thing is black
is the one who chooses the variation and
E 5 is playable Knight f6 is playable 96
is play will even be fighters playable
so you can you have a wide range of
options and especially Knight f6 seems
to be completely okay even for
professionals I mean Khurana is playing
it so it's not he knows his stuff
understanding the Queens gambit accepted
I don't know I don't know that book is
the rich eternal book there are so many
books around
can almost be move this gh8 mate yep
yeah all the berserk Inge at one point
again hid behind master Marik okay okay
the dash of them come focus this is
understanding the I did I wouldn't sure
about the books name you know I only
know the L chef
yeah let's go in five if black is not
fighting for the center I'm going to
check it recommendation for a night off
look oh my god no I'm not really I don't
know if they have been quite a number of
folks of course on the subject but I
really don't know what's good
aha now I know where this Dale Chisholm
kombuchas Cottam Antoninus ha ha ha
ok
a good info that you have this book okay
in the meantime I'm trying to win
against 256 by simply stomping him to
the ground on the kingside g4 f5 yeah
it's going to be dangerous what is Papa
what is Nikki recommending against
against the knight or Bishop g5 right
how can you memorize that I really would
want I really wonder how you memorize
these lines do you actually go to your
employer and you ask for vacation time
because you want to study the knight or
more or you don't have you inherited
large sums of money so that you can
afford to put away this time
okay f6 I couldn't do that before
because he had to sacrifice him now f6
seems to win
I mean Bishop g5 night office is about
is the sharpest stuff you can play no I
see a funny line he took with the rook
but it works now nevertheless like the
the Queen SEC he takes it Bishop h7 made
yeah
takes Bishop h7 mate it's pretty nice
okay I have to have taken the lead
give me a game give me a game all right
guys is quite high rated but okay I
observed the other game some why not
yeah currently I the Kings gambit I
forgot about that
I played my routine stuff in the
berserks I should probably go from stuff
like the Kings gambit in in a non
tournament situation where I'm not
deserting the berserk games I need it's
better for me to play something that I
actually know came so take this not if
that's okay he's six under fire and I'm
an exchange of of course that wasn't too
great
what black did here yeah you can I
really have good results with this
opening scotch four nights take that
I have no Grand Master norm if you mean
how many norms I have I have tons of I
am norms why do you only need the only
need three I have a couple of more but
it doesn't help anymore
yeah the timeI is going to try got three
connected passes really come on really
some people really enough to get
punished okay
yeah in the meantime I got overtaken of
course people want to play down the
whole house Master Marik yeah okay no I
don't have a grim arsenal I haven't been
closing you know I had good tournaments
but GM norm is stuff I really think it's
tough sometimes people make it sound
like it would be easy to get to get get
to get those I think it's tough really
do okay maybe I shouldn't have desert
this one nope position is fine but time
looks dead critical
I could try for teak and I g4o f7
blundered f7 it wasn't good but he
didn't take advantage of it let's see
does he take it or no okay whoop to h6
not the more subtle attack ever but it
could do the job maybe you want to see
you now
King f1 Queen h1 should win know it so
it should win but Marik has won a super
quickly people resign against him it
seems not against me whatever happened
here I mean we are both completely
killing the competition here like I had
20 points
pimentos guy crushed me earlier now he's
playing really strange stuff 95 could be
tricky 95 is a good move hmm I should
have handled that a bit differently when
I don't my 5 is kind of keeping
everything together but it's a little
bit a little bit uncomfortable that's
one of the those nights on e5 are so
great that looks extremely strange and
maybe I should have played a six in fact
sick of that friggin night
he's got 54 points head sick that's sick
really yeah a lot of this depends on how
people resign there if they resign a
rook down or not implants a huge
difference put it all on light squares
yeah I think this this is a complete win
but doesn't help I 93 I should've played
but how do I actually win maybe I have
to trade this not sure if that was a
great idea when I look at this one now I
probably wasn't
Jim this game I will win but you think
people enjoy losing on streams hmm maybe
and then that's the way it's the reason
why they don't resign didn't count what
exactly did I do wrong him not much to
be honest
I'm reasonably happy with what I did but
the angel he played two more games and
just like resigning early I am this is
the key
ok so let's play some viewers let's
let's to mania maybe I take longer than
before does help on the first move
yeah thanks for subscribing first byte
so help me
the earlier I wicked I am in Sim you I
think the simians are fun but I wonder
how long that would actually take yeah
you have to advise me on that a little
bit
no Fiona's also streaming here at school
she says she started tournament ok
similar one to one per player how is
that going to work
a delicious place on some of challenges
um okay what I'd like to do is I'd like
to play the the subscribers first 20
players 20 plus 20 oh okay
so help me F who is a subscriber Lord
Kinbote I think I knew is one yeah I
know I like the idea of playing a senior
I really like that
come on let's let's try that let's try
that so what do we do 20 20 plus 20 what
does that actually mean we have 40
minutes that probably takes a little bit
more than an hour right 20 plus 20
okay so extra clock time do I need extra
clock time probably I need 10 minutes or
something
so how much extra time do I need ten in
ten minutes or something 20 minutes okay
I don't know yeah let's do 15 I'll let
you see what happens okay
I'm going to create and once it is up
that first 20 I will accept
just top to bottom okay
[Music]
this is the right I have to do do it
like this
11:15 yeah 14 more okay 16 17 18 are
theirs except random okay
how do a closer 19 and the next one I
will pick and then we've got it okay so
let's start I have to be quick so so I I
will definitely explain stuff but I have
to get in some moves first and then then
we'll see oh my god this is like a video
game
yeah I'm playing my e4 abattoir
okay take it and yeah we've got color
panel of him
Scotch four nights probably we get more
of those later some french exchanges
yeah go see 3d form ot form before
[Music]
canceled
- I just I just ruptured you stuff that
I know at the moment and you have to be
somewhat quick otherwise the time we'll
time will kill you should be three
should be five cover the pond castle
yeah you have to have to be quick take 3
take yeah those two notes they are they
are tough business yeah there really are
and he's six wait just a moment there
what happens here okay I think I go back
take no I'm for first three takeand okay
yeah check yeah that should be good for
white age three is my line here's we
should be five is strong
fifty-three castles g6 that we can set
dark squares a lot ooh let's go see 384
okay here I've won a tempo which is nice
its develop should do it for Queen to it
to Bishop is six and that's a strong
move let's go see form but should be
true before night have 60s a 3d force
there dear 24 yeah it's just like you're
in some sort of then more day you just
play the moves that you know
c6 think I go f4 okay let's take keep it
simple okay Queen to e7 that looks
strange might have five looks good go
back to see - here I go see three until
form yeah Suren here knows his stuff
it was a bit of an accident yeah I
somehow stumbled into a mainline Carroll
that I don't really play I played the
two knights but I made a move on a
mistake let's cancel on the form good we
had this before Age 3
gained some time here yeah it looks like
I should have mostly comfortable
positions and there are some things that
kind of repeat you know they look
similar Oh Queen to b6 okay covering me
to go deform Knight takes hereby totally
not Luka okay it's develop Quincy -
looks good
g5 played and Bishop to c7 okay b6 could
be a problem here but I have to have to
really be quick take take here I
intended to give him the bishops did
have not denied I hope I didn't
I wonder where blood of the night you
hear the bishop are threatening to move
I have to get the Queen out demo yeah
here black is not going to Castle d5
okay
let's develop here recapture okay not
not the greatest situation probably them
that I created but okay I'll take this
keep the bishop and develop age six okay
off to go back night if I am taking this
night is good him
it's recapture recapture three oh there
are a rupee one that could be
interesting and there's a there's some
there's something possible that could be
quite attractive well we'll see him
castle
take this take this
I'm just going to cancel here so here
long diagonal okay that looks like a
good move
III there was a chick okay I need the
night to come to d5 okay
95 is actually quite a problem here
[Music]
okay I can take g7 here but I can also
do this huh take the Queen
any advice for getting better besides
playing more yeah time controls to help
you play a little bit longer time
controls that's definitely not a bad
advice but it's a bit tough for me to
moment to answer questions because this
is really a tough competition age five
okay wide to play and win
[Music]
so yeah night to detune when I could F
forward
I have blended h3 ah that's terrible
that was pretty terrible okay is six
going to double here
okay kind of d3 going to take ya blunder
83 in one move against bombas was
actually really high rated yeah to want
something and this is a bit awful
because the position was already
completely sucking for black before
blonde at that really it was really bad
from like I had the bishop pair for
absolutely nothing
I can't so um let's see drip drip drip
drip once to take take on see true maybe
hey let's develop take him let's go here
b5 okay yeah I should take this my
development here is not great I have
strategically speaking it looks nice but
I have to see that I'm not getting too
far behind I came here the queen is
right into the end run this diagonal I
have to go back so
[Music]
come on this and 95 is my idea but no I
have to do this first camera see form
night h5 yeah okay huh have to take
probably before is six okay no just keep
this og six looks tough the dead stuff
takes the rook and the knight on c6 okay
so I need somehow to regroup the night
so here yeah here RX has given up the
queen he was losing some some material
anyway oh gee form yeah this is an
interesting choice he tries to trade
trade Queens yeah
the threatened to take on g6 maybe an
idea okay rook has taken Knight f4 is
going to come which is a bit of an
annoyance
take this yeah eight yeah boom Shakalaka
boom Shakalaka doing a good job okay to
trade the bishop tier let's develop to a
good square develop again so King to g8
I need the pieces our you have but where
exactly where do I put them ninety-two
that's 9 f4 that's not good
my day three looks slow
in g3 looks wrong
okay but I have to make a move
centralized 96 year to again centralized
he has provoked weakness 94 by met renfa
isn't the h3 kicking this back [ __ ] it
is okay so yeah he won yeah boom
Shakalaka with 1500 completely outplayed
me okay you know he has high ratings he
just has a bad long time control rating
because he never plays it I came you
know so yeah here I'm in trouble after
blundering that that's stupid porn okay
let's get this out of the way now
develop yeah here do I win another piece
Queen e2 when I probably Castle so
that's develop instead Bishop e7 like
here central noise Knight comes to d5
next yeah
centralized as well okay 95 let's get
everything in the center oh that's not
so nice KH 3 between here it has to go
back you have six trying to put this on
g3 and centralize again double on the
e-file oh I didn't see this move coming
as a really bad game
on my end my part
huh
it shouldn't work she'll cheat six the
chip just six nine things I don't think
it does work okay tempo on the Queen to
take here yeah Andrew create it's
actually still a little bit tricky this
thing because I cannot cancel okay
Queen two is six somehow there is no
knock out yeah it looks pretty pretty
bad somehow but I don't I don't really
see your way to this one oh yeah this
looks good actually
okay so a c5 played here I need f4
somehow listen idea analogy six maybe
they are not threatening much how do I
get F for it in this in this position it
should be possible somehow maybe just
Queen e2 then f1 okay mile X antics is
defending this well really is K rupee
eight okay after gain some space look
III yeah yeah yeah not good not a good
position
rook t1 Bishop e3 Jake Jake look at the
one Bishop e3 rock - you don't know yeah
I have to go 90 for him and here it's
their way here to get more than as so I
only saw that it is I think it's okay if
five by all run nights at school 94 729
each five here going to castle 97 I came
well ok Quincy 5 maybe let's step out of
this 94 by rx um go back age 6 okay I
keep this okay Bishop takes is three why
am I playing such a long game
yeah because sometimes you can think you
know there's this more to chest and just
playing bullet every single time and I'm
just making fun sorry but it really is
the case you sometimes can play a bit of
a longer time controlling this it makes
some sense so um yeah what to do here
just not good not good at all night age
five so okay what's happening here a
five
let's go a five
yeah and yet the energy six is hanging
so Bishop e6 I could take it but I want
to centralize first queen ki ex-queen
cheeks and now what is going on here hmm
before
Quincy six it looks so shaky and
everything this Bishop is just about
covering this stuff but I don't see how
to how to exploit that maybe there is no
way to exploit it
push this first okay Knight to f4 yes
yeah I can check your Bishop f5 but it
doesn't really feel like it does much I
[Music]
can so queen g6 take this pawn yeah I
can just develop and check him yeah I
get completely killed by boom Shakalaka
here this one let's attack okay I keep
this closed so rupee hmm okay
okay so rook d8 Bishop g5 is a good
developing move and this also feels
right so I cannot play f4 which is kind
of a pain need more pieces though it is
a good way a good piece I am probably
bring the knight around yeah hmm okay
Bishop d8 by D Mac so here even have to
make there will be an uncomfortable
decision for him so here if I take this
so take with the GE pawn okay I'm going
to keep the Queen's on d5 to deform yeah
it's a decision I could resign this but
yeah who likes to resign not me yeah
this I thought I can take 24 but Knight
f4 is an issue
the real issue
okay oh he gives me d5 that is very
generous Knight f6 okay let's go back
yeah that's not good not good at all
okay
ninety-seven is about to come the ship
look everyone
or here unhappy three is good okay but I
have 97 right
yes that's winsome material 95 by Tigre
let's go here skill him and Knight to d6
hmm didn't have that on the radar that
much yeah yeah fifties therefore I get
it okay I don't want to take so let's do
this yeah thanks for the follow Alfa
skeleton
oh I've learned that Bishop g4 or okay I
mean if you blitz out every move that
can happen that's still not really nice
not really nice in a position that was
so one-sided centralized okay there's
really no way to play a discovery on
that night maybe this way and it's no
reason to drawn there was a drawer for
somewhere okay
g3 keep away squares
Quincy six was forced and I thought this
one Bishop is checking that's probably
Europa to draw I didn't see that
boom-shaka-laka really I didn't see it
wrong I probably would have to take it
just such a bad position
okay let's make a safe move in space
okay um let's get some play going there
and I have to recapture here look III
I'm not playing this well here against
our eggs not really he gets a bit more
activity than I would have liked him so
yet to be honest okay so um Queen do I
take it sure about it so he has taken
taken this we capture ninety five okay
is the moment where you enter age five
by totally not Luka so what to do what
to do what to do this up all night aged
five maybe yeah I mean I'm happy to draw
I can offer a draw against moon
Shakalaka but I'm clearly worse so if
you still like the draw I'm happy to to
take it of course yeah this I don't
quite know what to do Knight f4
okay let's take this Knight f6 back so
that is hanging cover it and and now
yeah thanks for the game boom Shakalaka
very nice game I think you completely
outplayed me down traders and now our
COO Leon okay I'm not sure that I want
to go f4 all that quickly Knight f6 yeah
I thought this is interesting maybe
that's a bad square for the Queen now
that I think of it like it should be
five or so now again I want some
conflict okay out here I can take it why
not
and ninety seven always going really
really really really though on the
defensive okay star neck Queen g6 okay I
can take care with the rocker let's do
it
Andrew P aids by Marco Rico okay let's
go him and King h8 okay I'm going to
really bring all the pieces into the
game and then see what happens queen bee
aid here by Lord Kinbote Queen e5 I'm
going to take and here
no I have to take first what the heck
what's the queen trapped or anything he
just gives the Queen okay
b5 by a Coolio okay I'm going to take it
because whoopsie one is coming Knight f6
okay yeah good defense here by totally
not new crown queen to d5 could be an
idea for him and sure okay rupee eight
played I'm going to take Bishop things
97 thinking huh
not sure that this is good though I got
b5 outside the Shimon c6 interesting and
going to be 5 so Wow there are some pins
now in effect he's 6 and 95 is good I
think how I was thinking I'd take that
what is the deal them does he have some
great some great move here Marco yeah
take with Luca on your form
Jim they have to take it's not looking
good
ok starak after sacrificing the Queen
still has a position because he was
material up sorry
before you thicker feist okay
Queen Jegs okay see one push push push
[Music]
g5 Satori attack more popular these days
ma'am I didn't recognize ya this is a
good good move I probably have to
sacrifice the Queen damn I have no good
good way to go I can't take on f6 maybe
and then take your form this is actually
interesting wait the Queen f6 the rook
takes a woman that's unfortunate Knight
h7 Wow where do those moves come from
never looked at that one hello okay it
really looks like I should use some
stuff here came a bishop is six um yeah
95 was my idea
g4 okay I can take f4 what is wrong with
that
one night h2 keeping everything attacked
let's do it it's a trade Queen before
yes he's attacking the knight which I'm
going to cover and Queen to d7 so c6 huh
take this and for centralization Queen
to d7 thanks for the follow okay fine
keeping everything there go back say any
is to anyone around who pulls banning
this idiot no way is that
okay so what to do here that looks good
yeah this is a really tough game to play
I would definitely love to have more
time there maybe this is good yeah just
to okay I'm a little bit more
comfortable here in this position
probably this is someone where you blend
everything scientifica take this take
this Bishop g5 so what's going on here
if I just take this take it okay here
I've got everything kind of lined up for
you five so I should play it at one
point but let's do this
I came what is this guy's glutes writing
okay it's a good writing no surprise I
think he's doing a good job there yes
well what would is that with all those
idiots crazy crazy people in the
chattering okay so take him yes this is
what I kind of thought that it could
happen but but I don't think it works I
can also take this first yes take this
mr. cheeks these three okay
take it okay so I've gained lots of time
here with this with the stuff with the
seaport and at some point I have to save
the rock which I'm doing now Bishop f5 I
did not pay attention that this is
possible
[Music]
[Music]
yeah I can't I can't imagine you had the
chat that Magnus called must've had must
have been chaotic yeah with with with
tons of people and whatever yeah
take this Queen D age hereby totally not
Luca yeah it's night age five of nine
takes age 590 group g6 doesn't quite
work yeah it doesn't quite work it's
kind of close it is closed Knight f5 yes
don't have much time there okay dance
this should be five is around so check
did I blunder something rook takes these
three looks very scary I don't think so
yeah it looks like this is heading for
repetition
and centralized g6 it's that way to
threaten like maybe I have to centralize
95 coming and T I'm out to come to e5 at
the end groups III Nia stick with the
Queen and here we're probably repeating
[Music]
okay a red cap don't understand the
position so it makes sense maybe to make
it wrong go back not trading and here
isn't 97 to [ __ ] yep
big big Fork okay let's go a five and
look a eighty and the solution against
bomb best this one this one I don't know
[Music]
yeah did Magnus really do much
commentary in hyper bullets I have a
hard time to believe it I think probably
it would do okay with commentary but
it's hyper bullet you know how do you
how do you actually commentate this and
probably don't
Quintus is 7l but I can take I can play
d6 also d 690 force also move 46 ok this
one and look a seven rook a seven so
we're here I'm kind of I'm not saying I
have enough for the Queen really not
that would be a bit too much but there's
something a position has some some
points okay I saw that one but shouldn't
have probably allowed Knight to g4 take
this and here
yeah at the end I win the house and with
mukade g6
I can probably take walking takes his 7y
this is good
no should you fall we are you okay
that's not good at c7c pawn running King
2 is 6 so this is a really really nice
position gain a lot more space and what
the heck Knight to Knight to g8 ok
Queen g6 buy my bomb best yeah my
structure is a little bit shake him
stick eyes got Ruby woman that one okay
did I blunder something here I don't I
didn't think so
cheery loud ok so just take him yep and
Bishop d7 so I think I'll take it
rook age 5
so just this him and then put her on to
f6 should win der should win it okay
go to the side
you should give four yeah thanks for the
game Eric's so cheeky
yeah but at the end I'm picking up see -
you know I'm picking up the c2 pawn
before this is something where you would
need a bit of time to figure it out okay
play slowly this is the main cause for
concern this game this is this is a game
that I could actually lose the other
games I think I'm okay I'm mostly better
in the end the others
[Music]
[Music]
then she five in [ __ ] up okay tick Oh
brave Bavarian thanks for the cheer and
it's nice so I can trate trate trate
trate that's not a bad thing with with
this kind of situation G 445 and you do
like oh that's a good move not trading
it's a bit tougher okay yeah he had rook
to be one which he unfortunately did not
play it would have been a bit awkward
trading all of a sudden so go back oh
this is made in one I think yes oh my
blind forward chest skills I don't know
I mean I'm definitely able to play blind
forward but I've never have never
practiced it absolutely never or tried
it out of it but I mean every somewhat a
strong player can do it okay I'm taking
thanks for the cheer Oryx
so is there some kind of attack 95 is a
discovery here doesn't do much
okay so Queen to e6 here I'm upper Tanya
a Pathan take this one I also have the
check yeah I know I know the the color
of the square is absolutely that you can
name a square and I know what the color
is that is not a big deal that would be
made in one Luke want to eat you okay so
yeah here these six a thought just bust
everything open or H 5 H 5 could be good
as well these six looks like the most
logical
I can't sell night a form coming you
know but I can take him I can't live
like this
activate huh
so this is unprotected him this system
way to know okay King jf7 by all run
night how am I going to win this game go
him and he just has taken it home
yeah I have the check but I cannot I
cannot sacrifice back
ok so between age 5 and yeah I can cover
it with this ugly move but ever night up
so it's not a big issue
ok Queen to f4
ok he wants to activate with 94
understandable
okay rookie five I didn't see that one
coming
it's a good move yeah hello - if she in
the chit yeah how am I going to continue
this was my idea I was just to think I
was just thinking okay is that really
doing all that much so how am I going to
put up some resistance one point is you
can always sack that back
and take on f7l doesn't really do much
know who create it and check meme a
group c1 and queen to b7 it's not great
I don't want to take their on a seven
that really sucks and leads to a bad
ending okay
ninety-four what noise me here quite a
bit
is the week back rank I definitely wanna
play some back rank really help for the
back rank move okay so here I did not
want to take it's a little bit better
for me for sure that's made next forum
let's go h5 Queen h4 so here I'm a look
up right it is the rook for a couple of
ports at middle and yeah I do a go to f6
or not I know I could be very offside
iam if I go to have six let's play more
centralized chess rook h4 yes Queen to
h5 or what's up maybe
that looks really ugly a queen trait if
I get the Queen traits traded it would
be okay
that's not doing much all I have to make
a move you know
okay rook c3 looking more at a three
mmm h g5 rook f5 and then I could double
wonderful fifith a little bit ambitious
anyway they have to make it move
reported offers a draw know that the
position is too bad I cannot take a drop
so taken him
yeah after Luke cheeks there is f5 but I
don't think that would work I will be 6
ok come up the pawn take mate so I
haven't lost the game yet that's not bad
Bishop d3 ok I did not expect this one
to happen but it's a it's a it's decent
I guess I shouldn't get my Queen trap
yeah that could happen on a very bad
game I could get my Queen trapped
my queen is really not well placed down
[Music]
it's not well placed absolutely not
I don't see a good move it's got 94
lined up this rookie to move wasn't
really doing all that much didn't really
spot Bishop d3 how do I come with that
Knight f3 mania simply Knight f3
okay let's do this first okay before see
if I can win this okay night to be six
here get this back
okay now 94 blunders the rook that was
one one point how do I ever get this and
I don't like this so much it feel to
shake him yeah this is a move that I
thought of but I thought I would have
the better ending maybe I'm wrong I
thought before his week yeah if you
attach a piece in over the board plane
you have to move it one two three
one thing that is sometimes forgotten
you have to touch it with the intention
to move it this is in fact important
because if you let's say yeah I can you
you pour some coffee or tea and yes you
somehow make and make a movement and you
knock over a piece yeah then you don't
have to move that piece because it
wasn't touched with the intention to
move it that's an important important
thing yeah you can't seize your dupe and
correct the piece placement if they're
set up in an in an imprecise way for
example night is six or take or not
[Music]
take it let's get this in yeah this look
Queen to be seven so not very active
move let's open this up a Korean has
suggested to draw I still like to
continue a little bit no you have to say
Jai Duke before you actually touch the
piece whatever one looking move yeah
probably it's okay it just still looks
wrong
jadoo means that you adjust the pieces
to make them yeah so that they are
better placed okay try to go for
counterplay yeah here okay six should be
strong okay Queenie two and let's get
this on the way okay
look to h5 what is Lord Kimber what's
doing here okay and I Coolio is going
back so it's Luke c4 now I don't know
maybe d5 thank you I'm happy to trade
shake we came this is almost checkmate
but I don't see there is I don't think
there is one
check yeah I don't know trade one walk
okay do this first Bishop c4 him he
still cannot go Knight e4 Knight h4
yeah looks strong looks strong I'm not
sure what it stretches yeah probably
just to take these three
don't truly see a good move him yeah it
sometimes happens say that you don't
react to a check-in system matter all
the time we have no time on the clock it
can easily happened it can easily happen
take care and oh that was actually a
mistake yeah I was thinking I was
thinking I have attacked the rook but it
is covered okay this is actually better
okay it takes these six was played here
by Sauron I can take I just wonder if
something else is good h5 for example
looks strong Age 5
that's not bad that's going 5 in the
rook c1 here by Marco Rico so I can take
this yeah and then he goes what hook our
queen to be severed
this is actually an issue iam
[Music]
okay I'll take it take this and be true
did a blunder be - almost
should have 6 min this early yes he will
forget to take this home ok ok keep
everything yeah this isn't threatening
mate this is the thing yeah maybe I
should have actually paid more attention
from them I don't have a move here rope
t5 but that sucks
so can i play 55
I see the ni was a city together that
was bad when I did okay trade the Queen
Bishop d3 okay
let's go here oh yeah the arbiters
decision in that cars li na kiev game
there was crazy a typical you know where
they get the arbiters for those events I
mean it's just the World Championship
yeah you just take some morons you would
do the Hobbiton I don't get it really
don't get it
it's completely completely terrible I
mean the thing is there are rules
of course yes but there's also common
sense and what the arbiter decided there
was absolutely nonsensical and it makes
sense to think this media rogue aged six
going to be made
so how am I going to do something Here I
am it's not much anyway and the decision
that they had the the the decision that
they made at the end was fine but the
initial decision to what
Inaki of the winners completely crazy I
mean who would think of such a thing
I mean you have to be completely
completely down to do that okay before
and stuff
oh that's not a good position not
okay there's a draw that came and now oh
oh nice shot here by bombas so I lose in
this game and that somehow expected yeah
it was tough to play I take and that's
made I'm going to put it on the board so
that you see why I'm actually losing
take this I'm a weak back rank here
right
be sure to eat I have rupee one here
should have six I can't take the pawn
take this and be five okay that's not so
ideal not not a huge thing with could
have that could have turned out better
King up
yeah I mean what did not have did I try
to get a win from this is of course I
mean those kind of actions I always
think are cool because then you
definitely know that you can file
somebody under this complete Sol
category just a good that was a
self-made wait okay so my time situation
this is really really bad really bad I
only saw that now how much I'm behind on
the clock in those games seven ongoing
okay got auto switch on which is
probably helpful
that's not pre move it's never my move
no way my move check this one it's going
to be it's going to be smothered made
double-checking against tonic
smothered meet last 190s 7m8 okay um
chicks he enters with the friggin rock
not so good this is going to be already
tough really tough night never for hug
him so for games so i think i shouldn't
lose on time did not do that I thought
it was a very attractive option to go
into the second rank but he didn't do it
okay so ever take D for him from me not
so bad he cannot take this you know this
is hanging kind of they have porn
okay let's move no G three kings you to
improve a little bit it doesn't really
help though shoot to g5 okay take it
yeah here I have some chances if I can
get I can get the right end game type
mmm
I cannot take here unfortunately this is
hanging
I had look at five okay not good not
good at all but then this one shoot I'm
losing this I thought I really thought I
was close to saving this game maybe I'm
just too much of an optimist
okay Queen here I don't want to trade I
know don't want to trade
once here tonight here and this one yeah
I was thinking look
hey to when she's got Queen to use sex
anyway I have to do it
a4 okay hmm
it's a bit of a pain don't want to take
this one made him how much for games
going on okay
good game me by Tigre think put this
straight just equal okay
okay Trombley this is equal a one Bishop
a one bishop what's going on here
kind of kind of what is that if you
wanted to shock me you you succeeded em
I take f7 here a one Bishop is just
crazy
I was a complete shocker a one Bishop oh
[Music]
thanks for subscribing with twitch prime
and okay
okay
[Music]
him any way to win ce7 I'm just pushing
those at home right
c7 yeah thanks for the game or a night
so still three games left okay if he
takes there I have I have perpetual x'
at least play c6 Tigra went back maybe
have some idea now he was the queen g5
coming
yeah c5 was a slightly slightly risky
decision slightly probably nothing
special but I don't I didn't want to
just draw
yeah this is taking it took it just took
a bit longer if then actually expected
but it's fun I like the stimulus okay so
yeah I can definitely perpetual him I
just wonder if there's anything better
I mean check check you know there's some
some there's some perpetual coming
probably if I go here okay and Quincy
one check check on h1 King to g4 it's
the check
where is the next check is that check
Bishop g3 King h3 and I can't you should
be able to run all the way to g6 okay if
that doesn't work it doesn't really
matter it's just it's just a game okay
g6 hmm I did not expect that one to
happen but it's a good move let's go
back go for yeah I 95 I wanted to go in
for two King e6 but here 95 also was
possible I don't have to blitz offices
just made with Queen g3 or cot yeah okay
as I said as I said if it loses it is
really not a big deal
so Queen g3 okay thanks for the game
Marco Rico he just beat me twice already
it's funny what's that some budet game
no to blitz games he beat me anyway um I
came I'm running into Queens III made
could have perpetual of course with with
the rooks
so I'm losing two games actually so this
is still going on let's activate the
Queen good take him
so those look I mean this this is
probably better for me the other one is
probably this is probably a draw
objectively speaking but I can try of
course before
queen is covering a seven maybe okay
maybe you're right kind of late over
here maybe you're right and I didn't
ever perpetual check I thought I had
perpetual them okay so that looks a
little bit shaky for black I've made a
little bit of progress in this position
Knight f6 as a move yeah sorry I can
take with a queen sorry
knight c6 I could try that would it take
in mind yeah may take him yeah so this I
should win
I think it's Lord Kinbote so I think
this is going to be AB somewhat decent
result and mostly wins crime
97 say anything they are probably not
nothing great okay okay I'm going back
going back here against Tigre okay I
could try to Kingi three get a bit of
activity going okay I can also check I
wonder if this is maybe more precise but
get get this going okay King F for ya
thinking F for threatens King g5 that
puzzle let's do it okay so here I can
check and then cover the pawn this is
some what is the simplest thing to do
yeah it should be enough so King ER for
he said I move always said completely
crazy it looks a bit crazier that's from
the 97 coming
if I call 96 now it said an idea
986 it's kind of it looks a bit strange
what I'm doing here maybe I'm just
killing myself okay um okay so cover it
it's a bit passive to be honest it's a
little bit passive I should pretty
should be enough
something simple would be king d5 and
Knight f4 trade G against age for that
would win pretty easily
okay so this one I did at least has had
some effect let's say yeah I can just
take g5 Queen d6 is also interesting
even queen bee aid could be okay okay I
just take this poor King t5
I should actually win I think I'm going
to win that one and the other one yeah
still slightly tricky with my king by
running all over the place
I can't I was thinking this is good just
trade the two points that should be fine
and then we know on the other side of
the board the knight coming to c4 looks
strong queen of two okay here I can
trade Queens if I don't see anything
better
okay I gotta trade Queens the b-pawn
should really win I don't think there's
any way for black to save that now so I
call the winner of this game where
nothing much happened for most of the
time okay tick now we a knight Knight to
c4 is still going to be going to be
quite good this one is also good yeah
that's a completely that structure is
just completely self-sufficient the King
cannot attack this and king before a3
should come
that's actually true
you should to see one yeah okay let's
bring this up 97 I guess
the other b-pawn is just going to
promote I think it's really not much
else going on so ever play c7 and also
King here and instead sue this okay so
he I think Knight to d5 his should work
F form and I just stopped the King from
coming up
fYI keeps those keeps everything covered
so naughty seventy but so that I don't
have to worry about him getting closed
down okay
the threatens Knight to e7 and promotion
okay
b7 Casey Sam
okie-dokie
yep so a night out Kingda six is what he
going what is going to try try to invade
you still have to look at this a little
bit and not be not to simply file it
away as a win so how to do it
Knight to King D 593 problem
[Music]
I just run with the King to the pawns
can see a bikini 5 candies 17 he [ __ ]
is 7
can you [ __ ] of something a [ __ ]
Jew said I'm too quick right and I'm too
quick I think for a game Lord Kinbote
you just said he resigned so King did
17d [ __ ] is 7 can you [ __ ] of 7
king of [ __ ] g6 yeah it should be 1 I
get all the points hope I'm not screwing
this up it's a bit late but I think it
should it should win
King a 14 g6 King g4 g3 this way so add
two losses and three draws with a couple
of wins probably 15 wins if I'm not
totally misjudged this which I don't
think I do
the dead actually is casual awright
simulus casual
[Music]
yeah tigress trying to find a defense
there but it's too late I think winning
quite comfortable him so you can
actually go to this year okay so you see
how the games ended here there was a
there was a nice one here with Bishop d6
made okay I was a there was a nice
smothered mate
there are some interesting games it will
of course funny yeah we're running to
Jeff let's issue over ah
[Music]
thanks thanks for subscribing Feynman
d-roc is obscure for two months okay
thanks
really unaware about some options or
unaware of some options yeah now it's
too late early Tigre
yeah thanks for the game tigress so the
similar we have had 15 wins three draws
two losses this is this is quite good
I'm happy about it I think it's a good
result and he had some really
interesting and cool games yeah I should
have lost against boom Shakalaka of
course yeah definitely I mean he was
very he was offering me a draw so that
was very nice of him but the position
was lost yeah I had the game me against
totally not Luka where yeah where I'm
not sure what was going on we had a
repetition and I think it was maybe okay
I mean I'm somewhat active here with the
pieces but it's possible that they are
not that well coordinated yeah this was
a nice Kimia against Raymond I think had
could control there most of the time
yeah so it's late it's late it's later
than originally thought I'm glad to be
back online and having a good stable
internet connection that's really
something I have to mention that stream
now is on for two hours 43 minutes and I
have not had a seem a simple frame drop
which is great really not a single frame
drop I hope the connection stays that
stable and reliable it is really
important to have this kind of stable
connection in the last one two weeks it
became worse and worse and it's also one
reason why I didn't stream all that much
simply because simply because my
connection sucked so much yeah I really
did not like to play even on on DJ's or
anywhere else because of bad back
connections so it is good now to see
that at least for the moment the
connection is fine thanks a lot thanks
all to all of you I saw that some of you
actually also from Germany is so really
really late on your end I'm going to bed
now you should probably do the same
thanks a lot for watching bye bye